yeah i guess uh going off of that i want
to ask like you know obviously you draw
god knows how many hours per day right
like i'm sure you've run into like you
know
injuries and like wrist problems like is
there like certain stuff that you do
like make sure you don't hurt yourself
well you have to have to do some stretch
yeah i have a message ball
to make for my hands to do stretch like
that or
do you wear like those like wrist guards
that i see some animators wearing uh
no not me but uh yeah every
one two hours i have to do some stretch
because sitting
and you have to also have a good seat
you could see do you have a good game a
chair at home
i don't remember the brown but yeah but
in fact i'm working on tablet
yeah so and for unfortunately i cannot
be like that oh you're like hunched over
right
[Laughter]
don't forget the microphone by the way
sorry um
i guess it's the same same kind of
precautions a lot of let's say like
like professional gamers and esports
athletes have to go through because you
you doing a lot of movements on your
wrist right carpal tunnel right yeah
yeah so sometimes i have been here
oh no message uh so yeah so i
in fact animators have to do sports also
because so i
sometimes i went to gold gym with my
friend
medi and to do some exercise
right and because yes you lost you lose
muscles
yeah yeah yeah i definitely feel doing
youtube as well because i'm sat at my
desk all day
yeah i got to do something yeah with the
coroner so now you
yeah you don't you don't leave much you
don't move much yeah
yes to the desk to the fridge right yeah
as as like a teenager sitting at your
desk playing video games
all day and all night whatever you never
think about oh
what are the ergonomics right now you
know you never you never think about
what part of my body am i injuring
yeah exactly i did feel bad because when
i use i used to play games like
you know pretty much from after school
until i went to bed yeah and i never had
any problems and my other friend would
play like two hours a night if he was
lucky and he got carpal tunnel
oh geez he's that and i was like you're
weak
real gamer don't listen to it you ain't
a pro gamer
look at that look at those weak wrists
get out of here
those aren't gamers get some real thumbs
up
i was just like worried i'm like why are
my wrists not giving in and yeah this
men's are giving in like
the most chad wrists yeah maybe i came
out the womb
just like racist it's like natural
selection like shows you in the wrong
way
you know my kid is going to have like
jacked wrists
like natural selection is going to kick
in and like
oh my god so yeah so most of when you
are young you can stay
more longer just start your work hard
but when you get older
you have now a family kids and you can't
afford to stay yeah
go back to to home and well no no one of
your senpais can draw so fast they
need to otherwise that's the other way
and they was trained to
so right and those this pressure
and these are those deadlines make them
more faster and faster but
and good you have the quality yeah but
sometimes
when you you know not to have a much
experience you have to get faster and
sometimes you have to sacrifice the
quality
yeah and uh i i suppose are those the
scenes that
kind of always get memed on on twitter
and social media and stuff like that yes
and as i also you have you know just
seen
well there was a a bit a mess
uh some because of the communication
wasn't good or with the assistant
production
the animator didn't have time to do it
or so the animator couldn't do it okay
we have nobody
okay we'll give it to china korea to do
it and
and train across oh we don't have time
we have to speed it
right that makes sense seven deadly
scene this depends
also which studio will do it right
because sometimes you have a
gloss so for example if you have statue
a
we'll do all the episodes of 12 episode
but oh we don't have much time
we have to do uh we will do just a ten
episode and
the two other will be done by different
studio so they will ask to study b
and c to do each one episode and
if a b and c don't have the good stuff
it looks bad
you have some accident and also
more than the studio you should more
look just tough
stuff the studio is like a shell
at the moment yeah yeah the statue will
give a good
good environment to for a good working
place for the animators
and a good assistant productions but all
the skills and
all the the stuff will be all in
freelance so
it's a studio who uh okay if you we
you can do this project and we can give
you a good
working place yeah because i've always
wondered because you know there's
there's always like the meme in our
community where if if an episode is
animated well versus an episode that's
animated bad
we always talk about like oh it's it's
the budget you know they're not they're
not
giving enough budget but like how like
how
how true is that how is that actually
reflected or like is it
do they have is it all about the staff
that they can hire and the stuff that's
also the stuff yeah there's a lot of
things in fact you have also the budget
but
for example you have an episode you have
a lot of action a lot of movement
actually one episode it's a 350 cuts
but for some a lot of heavy episodes a
lot of action
epic episode can have a 500 cuts
right so for this episode it will be
more expensive
more expensive per car yeah per cart but
so for the next episode you have to
adjust this
right right right so so if you had the
climax on
episode seven so maybe episode eight
will be more
cool right and you talked about some
animators being more experienced and
more skilled and like
have making a name for themselves can
they um can they negotiate a higher
price per cut yeah yeah actually yeah so
so the rate of the cut is uh
when you when you have the offer and
they said you the rate of the cut
is this so most of the series is uh four
thousand uh
500 yen right i don't know 25
45 yeah for one cup one cut okay
okay so one cut can take you like
one hour one day today
[Music]
five dollars for two days of work or
sometimes
it can take you one week
i know a great website called fiverr you
might
so um so like that you you you can ask
excuse me
uh you you you try to negotiate
you have to negotiate for this cut it's
a bit uh
heavy cut can you put it twice or two
right right twice the price or three
times the price please
you have to negotiate and sometimes if
you are very very famous like
who we call this a super animator like a
one-man army yeah right you say my rate
is this
okay okay they want you yeah they want
you because you just
like a veteran and major they have the
name value or because
yeah in the show people want to look it
right
so that's kind of how like it works with
like youtubers too right this is like
if you're a famous youtuber that has so
much years of experience then you can
just be like yeah you know i mean
honestly if you've made a name for
yourself you deserve a higher
right actually we can say that it's a
bit like soccer
teams when you oh i want to one on
ronaldo or you want
messi you gotta pay the money right yeah
is that why
whenever you see like the climax of a
big
scene especially in like some shown in
anime or like some big you always see
the same names animating uh
same names yes all some new ones and
because
some you you cannot read all only of
some few names you have to find
new talent